we still got a lot of work to go as far
as the NFL season and let's talk about
what happened in the NFC because the
playoff picture changes again with
yesterday's outcome for now for now the
Seahawks are the number one seed pending
tonight's outcome between the Colts and
the Saints but the Seahawks by virtue of
their win cross country against the
Panthers KJ Wright's Seahawks linebacker
told me after the game they will never
take the Panthers for granted they don't
care about the record it's a tough team
and they got number 22 Christian
McCaffrey you have to be ready to go and
they let the Panthers kind of creep back
into it but they held on to win so for
now that the 1 seed Packers are the to
see they got the 21 to 13 win over the
Bears they were up 21 to 3 and they let
the Bears creep back into it and we
almost had a band is on the field type
moment yeah where the Bears if they you
know and I don't know how much teams
practice that last play but it sure felt
like when you'll watched it but they had
walked through the visa they really
weren't buttoned as buttoned up as they
could yeah when it happens because it
really has your mind got held on to the
ball a little bit too long
Alan Robinson was there to catch the
flip and score if he just opens his eyes
and doesn't you know worry about tucking
the ball and the defender I mean he's
gonna pitch the ball here's the last
play anybody's watching it you know Joe
Brisky throws it to the left and Tariq
Owen this is these are plays that you do
run I mean I'm sure the Bears this is
not their first time these are things
you do at the end of a maybe a Thursday
practice or the Saturday walk through a
book I mean Alan Robinson looks like
he's gonna walk in the end zone look how
angry Alan Robinson he's like pitch the
ball we would have scored that was
unbelievable a little bit an amazing but
they still what I the gun favored
Haywood had they would have had to
convert the two-point conversion and
they would've had to win in overtime but
it really would have been something to
see it happen but the Packers get the
win they're 11 and 3 they are one win
away from winning the NFC North after
two years of no playoffs under Mike
McCarthy Matt Lafleur coach of the Year
candidate by taking the package to that
11 and 3 record the Saints 10 and 3 they
win the night they're going to be back
in the ones a ones right they own the
tiebreaker with the Seahawks
this is where it starts to get
complicated we're actually yeah I don't
burn a lot of mental energy on these
hypotheticals because it'll shake out
when it shakes out but it will three-way
tie between
Seahawks Packers and Saints I would have
to apply the tiebreaker rules when there
are three or more times the conference
record but I know I'm not sure either
and right now the conference record
based upon the information we have in
front of us would do the Saints are
eight and three the Seahawks and the
Packers are eight and so they would have
the lead then so maybe it doesn't change
if they win tonight I don't know either
way like you said that's why I love this
stuff wait until week 17 and figure it
out when it's all over number four seed
we know that when that's simple it's the
Cowboys or the Eagles yeah one of those
two teams is going to be the fourth seed
by virtue of winning the NFC East and
what in the world with the Cowboys the
Cowboys lost three in a row they were
lost they were listless they were
uninspired and the Rams were the hottest
team in the NFC if not the NFL other
than the Ravens and the Cowboys blow him
off the field
Flutie 421 it wasn't that close I mean
the bludgeoned them beat them up in the
line of scrimmage I this is kind of what
I thought Seattle would do to the Rams
last week a little bit on Sunday Night
Football I thought they'd have their way
in the run game I mean the Cowboys
basically just dominated the Rams like
the Rams got dominating against the
Ravens where they just they couldn't
hold up in any one area but again I
think it just shows you a little glimpse
of a team that is what then the number
two offense in football has a top 10
defense and yes it makes no sense that
they're 7 on 7 and 7 but it just shows
you their ultimate you know capabilities
yesterday they have elite talent on the
Dallas Cowboys that's why they're
dangerous and you know a lot of that
they've been I guess my big thing with
end-times there are a lot of yards and
not enough points that speak to the
yards yesterday they capitalized on all
those yards and some of those big drives
we talked about early on in the game 15
play drive 14 play drive that was just
domination execution physical domination
a few plays here and there but dak
Prescott and the zekiel Elliott I
thought looked as good as I've seen him
look in a long long time
but that's why the NFC is amazing the
worst team in the NFC Pie operation
right now is 7 and 7 and I could sit
here and tell you they're the most
talented team in the NFC and that's
where it gets scary and that's where
it'll be interesting yeah I think that
if the Cowboys can
this up in the big test is this weekend
yeah the Eagles have won two in a row
now coming from behind right but against
clearly I team right right so what what
translates better to next week when
Dallas and Philadelphia get together in
a late afternoon window is it that the
Cowboys blew out the Rams or is it that
the Eagles have shown resilience because
if it's a close game yeah I'm gonna feel
like the Eagles have a piece of history
to carry them through yeah but if the
Cowboys play like they did yesterday
yeah it may not be a close game I put
more stock into what I saw from the
Cowboys yesterday I guess you know the
Redskins I mean the the Eagles but their
win over the Redskins yes again I don't
think their offense it's gonna be tough
sledding but yet they put up 34 points
yesterday against the defense that's
pretty well coached and got some talent
but Carson Wentz was phenomenal and then
they found a run game behind Myles
Sanders that was huge the thing that
worries me more than anything about you
know the Philadelphia Eagles right now
is their defense I mean just their
defense letting up big plays and big
moments and then again yesterday the
Redskins you know they ran the ball
pretty successfully Dwayne Haskins I
thought had his best day as a young
professional so that's encouraging but
they let up drives and big plays right
now and that's concerning when you got
the Dallas Cowboys coming in in town who
you know as we know have some weapons on
the offensive side of the ball and
certainly can make big plays and big
moments and and just the consistency
hasn't been there for the Cowboys this
year can they continue to play like they
did yesterday when they pack it up and
take it on the road for essentially an
NFC East championship game because the
Eagles have the Giants week 17
Dallas has Washington I would say that
whoever wins the game Saturday yeah or
Sunday rather between the Cowboys and
the Eagles that teams most likely to win
the division I think that team takes
care of business the following week when
the division title was right there to be
had right well and it won't even matter
right I mean it does it could matter it
could man I don't think it's gonna be
clinched this weekend no I don't think
it's gonna be clinched especially if the
Eagles win because they'll be split with
the Cowboys the Cowboys could force a
tie week 17 and get in with the superior
division but if the Cowboys when it's
over I think
they've swept it right Opie they'll be
swept it and they'll be up a game you're
right and that creates the scenario that
we discussed last week where they get
the by they they get a de facto by they
can rest their starters against
Washington up and face a team like the
49ers of the Seahawks and the 49ers
could really use a buy at this point
yeah and they're gonna be whoever loses
that bloodbath in Seattle is gonna be
limping into Dallas the following
weekend that may make it easier for the
Cowboys to knock that I that's just I
feel like that's the way it's gonna work
the Cowboys are gonna be 8 and 8 or 9
and 7 yeah and the the Seahawks of the
49ers are gonna come in at 12 and 4 and
and the 12 and 14 is gonna lose yeah
well I mean yeah I would not be shocked
you're right yeah I would not and you
know again to speak to the bigger
picture of the NFC right now the number
one and number two seeds are of course
Seattle and Green Bay as we sit here
right now at this moment and they have
laws as a football team I mean they
really do they have more flaws than the
Saints and the 49ers I know that and you
know again I'm worried about the Packers
they'd win what football games I get
that in the Seahawks too but man their
defenses
you know they just they they have
moments where they just let they get
gash run game pass game I mean come on
the Seahawks past events I don't know
where it's ranked right now but it's
it's X is injured now to know that's
huge because he's been a huge boost to
their secondary their 29th and football
and past defense the Packers are 22nd
and football and pass defense and can't
stop the run either so you know that
that to me is like kind of the funny
thing about the NFC right now is the
Seahawks and Packers even though not
always dominant have found ways to win
football games and then here they are in
them in the power position right now
think about this the top three seeds and
the fifth seed in the NFC currently have
three losses yeah the sixth seed has
four losses they're all packed together
and then there's who doesn't belong in
why the Cowboys at seven and seven it is
an amazing year in the NFC it is a
top-heavy conference and and you know by
virtue of the fact that the Rams lost
and they still could finish ten and six
and not get in I hate to see a team with
double-digit wins not get in when is it
with single-digit winds that does get in
it's gonna be hard to argue it after
yesterday yeah but it may that's right
you're absolutely right after but the
Rams had their chance and rands got
blown off the field right I still don't
like to see ten and six eleven and I
know then I know it does it doesn't seem
right you're right but yeah they had
their opportunities they bone a few
games throughout the year and there's
some close ones the Rams as it may be
but the NFC is just it's it's gonna be
really interesting to watch it all
unfold when all said and done because
nobody's just got an easy schedule
either that's the thing you look at like
you know your Vikings at the six seed
Vikings bear I mean Packers Bears that's
not easy you know the 49ers Rams and
Seahawks holy cow you know the path the
Packers got the Vikings and at the Lions
okay they should win the Lions game
easily but that Vikings game of course
is gonna be huge so there's a lot a lot
of football to be left to be played to
see where the seating happens and I do
think seating is gonna be about as
important as it's ever been as far as
the NFC playoffs are concerned this year
something I probably will be doing when
I get home is breaking it all down and
trying to figure out how I work because
I you know I the Vikings at least could
still get a bye right in the NFC
depending upon some of these jerseys
they're gonna need some unlikely
outcomes like the lines beating the
Packers week seventeen right
but the Lions you know they played the
Buccaneers tough and Matt Patricia may
be trying to make the best possible
closing argument for another year for
himself beating the Packers week 17
could be it and I keep hearing that
Matthew Stafford wants to play again
this year well if he's going to play at
all it would be week 17 carry on Johnson
come back in play so there's still a lot
to be determined that's the fun of this
season the NFC like I just look at it
and go the Seahawks and Packers if they
want to go to the Super Bowl they have
to have the first round by I guess
that's how I view it where I don't
necessarily look at it that much way
with the Saints and 49ers I do feel like
they have teams that can go on the road
they've kind of proven that that can win
games and those kind of moments where
yeah I feel like the Seahawks and
Packers they got flaws with their
football team they need that home-field
advantage
I feel like home-field advantage means
less than just getting the week off the
week off is gonna be critical yeah I
think all these teams can win on the
if they have to but you don't want to
have to play wildcard weekend right
because just advancing out of that
morass is gonna be a fight and think
about it for the team that loses the
Seahawks 49ers game week 17 you follow
that up with a playoff game you have a
de facto playoff game then a playoff
game and then you're facing somebody
that's had multiple weeks to get ready
yes I think that's obvious difference
intentionally
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports